winter sports are under threat
the multi-billion dollar industry the
livelihood for many mountain communities
faces a double problem
the popularity of skiing and
snowboarding is declining in the rich
world and resorts are having to cope
with a warming
climate this luxury hotel is the
birthplace of winter sports
welcome to the cool hotel in saint
mary's switzerland
in the 19th century switzerland was a
popular summer destination for english
tourists
the owner of the comb at the time
johannes badroot wanted to fill his
hotel all year round
nobody came in winter the people were
afraid of avalanches of coal
so in 1864 he made a whiskey fueled
wager with some english guests
we are in front of this fireplace where
the famous pet was done
the last english guests were about to
leave and he offered if they come in
winter and they like it they could stay
as long as they want if they didn't like
it he would reimburse them all the
travel expenses
the englishman returned for christmas
and became so hooked on snow pursuits
that they stayed for three months
soon others followed and winter holidays
were born
along with their tweed suits and
pinafores the english guests brought
their love of competition
with the post-war economic boom and the
introduction of mechanized ski lifts in
the 1960s winter sports soon became all
the rage
fashionable ski suits appeared on the
slopes and while the style of the time
was questionable
the industry brought wealth to poor
mountain valleys
but these days the outlook is darkening
skiers in rich countries are gradually
leaving the sport
and younger people are less inclined to
take it up
many head to cheaper hotter destinations
for winter sun
in the last 10 years the number of
skiers in the world's major ski
destinations has fallen
locals here are worried
ladies and gentlemen we now welcome the
british team
the team is ready for start the run is
clear let's go
for samarits and other mountain towns
like it
winter sports are essential to people's
livelihoods
segments would not be the same without
winter sport
it is very important for the local
economy they have a lot of jobs
it's very important for the local people
another major worry is the warming
climate
since pre-industrial times average
global temperatures have risen by one
degree
but the alps are well above average
temperatures here have risen by two
degrees
in the swiss town of davos scientists
have been measuring the amount of
snowfall and the depth of the snowpack
for nearly a century
the snow season starts later and it ends
earlier so that means the duration of
snow cover is getting shorter
even though there was a lot of snow in
davos this year
long-term trends show snowfall has been
declining for decades
and the depth of the snowpack has been
thinning since the 1950s
ski resorts have responded to the
problem by investing heavily in snow
making machines
if there is less and less natural snow
it means the lower elevated ski resort
get in trouble
currently they invest a lot in the
production of artificial snow
artificial snow uses a lot of power and
water it's clear that there will be less
snow in the future the question is just
how much less and how fast this process
goes
in some places snow making has allowed
resorts to extend the ski season
but in a warming climate resorts will
increasingly look like this
many may close by the end of the century
because they will not have enough
natural snow
and they will be too warm even to make
artificial snow
take this region of the eastern alps
scientists calculate that if
temperatures increase by 2 degrees about
15 percent of resorts may have to give
up on skiing
if temperatures rise by 4 degrees
60
may be forced to close
[Music]
the big hope for winter sports now lies
in asia
here in pyeongchang south korea they are
hosting this year's winter olympics
the popularity of this year's games and
the next here in china in 2022 will be
crucial to attracting new enthusiasts to
the sport
china and south korea are both cold in
winter
but neither olympic venue has much
natural snow
yet the organizers here are confident
the games will be a success
south korea in the winter time is
actually the dry season however the
pyeongchang region at 700 meters above
sea level is perfect to make artificial
snow the snow quality will be
up at the olympic level
in chinese ski resorts such as this one
in chongli district winter sports is
already booming
the number of skiers and snowboarders is
increasing by about 20 percent a year
it's estimated that nearly 500 new
resorts will be built in china ahead of
the 2022 winter games
in 1864 johannes badroot made a gamble
that paid off
the comb hotel has remained a favorite
destination for wealthy winter sports
fans
san maris is high up in the alps so the
fun is likely to continue for decades to
come
but even here they'll have to rely more
heavily on snow cannon
that's expensive and the cost will be
passed on to the skiers making the sport
even more expensive and exclusive
on top of this power hungry snow cannon
produced more greenhouse gases
those will add to global warming that's
melting the snow and ice
[Music]
you